that's one question yeah let's get a
question though all right
I'm hopeful Cajun fried rice hi I hope
you guys are doing good big fan of the
podcast I'm a 24 year old male from the
UK until recently I'd been working about
an hour in a local pub my friend's dad
who must be about 70 was drinking there
pretty regularly about three times a
week I'd met him a handful of times over
the past five years or so and his son is
one of my best friends he is old and a
very devout Catholic who currently works
in the church into my knowledge always
has I've got a bit of a weird vibe from
him and he started to seem even weirder
after he recognized me in the pub he
started off by giving me big tips of 5
euros and 10 euros and holding my hand
for like 10 seconds when he gave him to
me and he just would stare into my eyes
saying all these weird complimentary
stuff about me at the risk of sounding
like a dick I'm fairly attractive guy
and gross and I've got it quiet of a lot
of attention growth I also have a look
quite young young they know the way I
look and I can easily pass for 18 yeah
me too dude especially 47 after I shave
after a few months of generous tips from
him and weird encounters with him one
day he had about five large glasses of
red wine and got pretty drunk as I was
walking around the pub collecting
glasses he called me over to him and he
pulled me to one side
he said no Liam I've got a proposition
for you well first off I just want to
make it clear I'm not gay I'm not gay at
all man but what I do have is an
appreciation for the male form I used to
have a boy who I would pay a hundred
fifty euro a week to allow me to look at
his naked body for two or three hours
during the week I wouldn't touch him or
force her to do anything he would simply
get undressed and I would appreciate his
body from a distance does this sir not
something he'd be interested in I
immediately said no but I wasn't a dick
about it
I kind of laughed it off and was like
sorry I'm not interested I was actually
kind of flattered fast forward I
realized I'm 24 but honestly I could
probably pass for 18
maybe even younger I've got no beard I'm
skinny and just generally boyish looking
alright alright alright
definitely more of a boy than yeah yeah
come on come on I basically get without
doing something illegal anyway so my
question to you is should I bring it up
with my friend what should I do
it would be the most Awkward [ __ ]
thing to say to one of my best friends
your dad wants to pay me to get naked in
front of him so my gut instinct is to
just never mention it to anyone but a
second opinion a second opinion would be
great
my question is he's like I'm gonna watch
you from a distance like how far of a
distance are we talking like I don't
know like a [ __ ] football field away
a hundred yards baby babe we need your
opinion
Oh what does he do did she take does he
tell the friend about the dad no you
can't tell your friend yeah what I would
do is how much is he charging 50 euros
which is two hundred three dollars okay
I would do I would go
listen night helau talk back yeah okay
I'll might you all like I would like to
UM consider your proposition or 150
years now now now listen I have some
adjustments okay
I'd like a thousand a year I'll hear me
out and then I'll put the line between
you and me okay I put a line so you
can't cross the line and eight hundred
yards away that's a whole that's eight
football fields what's up one football
field 100 yards hundred yards away okay
my bad my god about honey gods away I
will dance around naked
I'll give you binoculars you can jerk
off if you want it I didn't ever say
anything about jerk off if you want it I
want it well I'm giving you the option
thank you for the option she has yes and
on yeah okay
I appreciate the male form so let's do
it alright and then we do it yeah he's a
thousand pounds every time you can jerk
off I did say that I allows I don't want
I don't want to jerk off guess what yes
Cheers
okay and I would just that but if not
that no don't tell the friend yeah yeah
what do you how do you open that up yeah
I'm the guy I'm the friend you're the
guy Simeon yeah that's Charlie you've
never called me Simeon before you look I
see me under me did you want to talk to
me I guess so what's up your father has
been coming into the bar Lane my
masculine father who like devout
Catholic who likes to [ __ ] the [ __ ] up
on my mother thank you for telling me
that
I know I am I was weird but similar
qualities to my name is Ricky God so
your dad has been giving me weird vibes
lately oh that's interesting
he proposed this thing where he wanted
to pay me and he wanted to appreciate my
body time but what you stopped me
there that's it that's it that is pretty
English yeah you would do some [ __ ] like
that you talk about my father is true
they probably go down yeah I wouldn't
say a thing it's not like the dad did
anything illegal like if I can you know
grab your dick or anything he just asked
nicely it's gay gay yeah but he's a
[ __ ] Catholic like that pressure of
like not being able to live your true
self I know this in this society can we
just be who we are
yeah if you're gay gay be gay gay you
know if you're American Indian be
American Indian you know yeah it'd be
that you know
[Music]